citizens of the reject Nation we got
ourselves a Godzilla X Kong trailer
today how are you I'm pretty good how are
you I'm excited man last night my wife had
the uh my wife had the choice of what do
we watch and she chose Godzilla versus Co
so I in a super big mood right now sized
mood for Godzilla X Kong the new Empire so
you know what to do leave a like on this
video people we got so much stuff coming
out so make sure to subscribe and click the
notification Bell enough chitchat let's get to
it
2001 seismic activity Monarch Legacy of
monsters most of human civilization Egypt
the wonders of the world that Li life
could only exist on the surface of our
planet uhuh I back aall sounds like looks
like Transformers tra yes rench the Fallen
he's got armor it looks like Transformers
yeah what else were we wrong about you wrong
Kong oh oh you got that that music back
just like uh the last one you come on in
yes more secret oh they got new ships yeah
they got Anime ships she got short hair now was
that Caesar oh who's this little guy
son of Kong is that danad stens the
guest reunion po could have done this I'm so
[Music] excited it's personal the rise of a
partnership wow is that Gia he's back yes my
dude stop this on his own he won't be alone
wow the visuals are so much more oh wake him up
that my be is that a different creature is that
Godzilla whoa what
what
damn oh my goodness oh damn
dude Holy balls yeah this looks
wild oh my God this is going to
be the greatest movie of all time buddy
cops is that a mini Kong the son of
[Laughter] Kong oh my God I am so jacked
right now I am excited but you know what
I'm most excited for them new monarch suits that
they got rocking on man most definitely drips on
those Monarch agents looking fly is so important
and you know what man they could look even more
fly this holiday season with some reject apparel
at www. reation shop.com where you get shirts
like this one of Pedro Pascal Child Protection
Services you can support just being a citizen of
the reject Nation with a real reject ticket Stu
sure but we also got space babies of the Galaxy
who influences The influencers Watchman inspired
America's ass homelander shirt with his Riff on
Captain America you know how it goes and then
we got bat verse we got a whole bunch of other
te's and whatever you decide to get is a great
way to support the channel it's a great gift to
get people for this holiday season we make sure
the shirts feel comfortable and it's an excellent
way to support the channel my personal favorite
way you can do it all right let's talk about this
man okay wow all right well I feel like uh Adam
Wingard is the director yes yeah I think Adam
winguard you know he got his feet wet with the
last movie I think he did an excellent job when
it came to everything involving the Kaiju and now
after last night I will have seen the last movie
three times at this point and I still think like
man he really excelled when it came to everything
with the monsters and especially bringing Kong
a genuine personality and a character to connect
with and you can just tell that he's got a
refined skill I heard that there's going to
be many sequences in this movie one that might be
up to close to 10 minutes where it's just going to
be visuals of just the animation fights just the
monster not just no I mean just like scenes like
a scene not even just a fight scene okay okay
yeah yeah yeah yeah sure because like the best
parts of that movie are the scenes with Gia and
Kong and Godzilla stuff that doesn't really have
anything to do with the humans you know yeah she's
the bridge between the humans that nobody cares
about and the bustard well it looks like here that
we're going to have um I I heard that the the name
of the villain and I could be wrong about this
I heard that the name of that ape villain I is
called scar King oh um I could be wrong could be
wrong stellin scar King stellen Scar King and that
so he will be the main villain and that he could
have some type of other creature that's a about
the extent of this the rumors I've heard sure
this new ape monkey so I feel like we'll have two
different things here it looks like we're going to
have that bad guy to contend with that Kong finds
in Hollow Earth scar King which we will need the
aid of this evolved Godzilla with yeah and then
there's this other tribe which I imagine by the
end Kong would be like the leader ruler over the
yeah that's because he found a thing to be a king
over we in Hall Earth the last movie he just found
a chair to sit on with an A and now he's going
to have people to rule my wardr my accessories
now I need my kingdom subject whatever where I
go this Godzilla wants to fight me where I go
we finally got peace and now I need to R over
some people um and then with an age of like
having Monarch Legacy of monsters with having a
Godzilla minus one and then having this franchise
to get an involve Godzilla with a distinguished
look one that is very much disting distinguished
uh I I think is a really smart call but this
just looks more like they they're zeroing in
and focusing in on everything that made the last
movie work so well they're getting they're going
to see they're going to spend most of our time in
the hollow Earth we're going to spend most of our
time with the actual Kaiju and creatures uh this
the scale and Threat Level looks massive and epic
uh I'm I'm really I really love Godzilla versus
the only thing I don't really like is the Billy
Bobby Brown and Brian Tyre Henry story outside of
that wow yeah I know it's unpopular opinion nobody
shares opinion I mean I don't mind the the Monarch
characters but but them I was like that's the plot
one I'm really not a big fan sure but everything
else I really love I think it's such a fun movie
and and this I imagine will while it's like a
serious trailer I I feel like they'll probably
go even uh they'll lean into some of its more like
strange wackiness at the last movie had yeah I
mean I have hope for that because I feel like Adam
Wingard of all the monsterverse movies managed to
find like an agreeable tone uh mashup between yeah
stuff that is like endearing and actually touching
with Kong and Gia and and that side of the story
but then you know bringing us the requisite sense
of fun that Adam Wingard usually kind of has
on his projects and stuff like that and yeah
this seems like something where look so good look
at the visual that that like Fusia you know glow
in the back plates and stuff like that and you
know like every Godzilla movie there's always
some kind of twist on the look and the power set
and all that stuff and and what it means when the
you know the the um Atomic breath is especially
so it's so hot now it's purple or something like
that just them running together well he's got his
Thanos glove his he's going to snap half of so it
must be something that Monarch helped design for
him I imagine or or is it some type of ancient
weapon that they used prior because it looks
like something monar D that will get you closer
to your Transformers crossover hent Tech I mean
he always needs some type of tech thing right but
but last time now he need it shows the Threat
Level for them to be um yeah for them to have
to really partner up yeah no 100% you know after
the uneasy Alliance last time and the respectful
kind of sendoff but like this the last movie had
those I'm curious about how much this is going
to resemble some of the movies it's reminding me
of because the last one you know obviously with
Mecha Godzilla and stuff like that you have the
whole like Batman v Superman element and in this
I'm getting shades of like stuff that reminds
me of both the early phases of 2001 but also
more over the recent like Planet of the Apes
movies where I'm like is Kong gonna be dealing
with some kind of like factional dispute that
he needs to yeah like you know whoop this scar
King's ass to settle uh I mean for Godzilla to get
involved and to be teaming up with Kong be Earth
threatening something tells me that the scar King
and Godzilla maybe have a got beef yeah that maybe
there's a history with them you know CU every the
mon the KA you all come from Hollow Earth so maybe
there is a history there that makes Godzilla be
like that son of a [__] is B I got to get it on
the action he's he's going after my My Little My
little monkey my My Gods son I like the look of uh
son of Kong if that's who that is uh I think it's
just another tribe okay I I was they don't look
like Kong I think I think it's going to become
like he's going to be like again I imagine is
going to be like surrogate cuz they don't look at
all like they're the same ty not all apes are the
same joh yeah I'm sorry I didn't mean to be a
big it against no it look it looks like that's
a completely different tribe and then and then
there's going to we're going to see other members
of this tribe yeah and then Kong's going to watch
over them and then it looks like too that there's
elements here where you're going to see are Gia's
people from The Hollow Earth as well because you
got all these like humans in a different
civilization here as well so it looks like
you're going to see that there must be yeah they
must be the special people who live in uh whatever
in shangi you know they live in uh I keep want to
call it conun but that's not the right property
right yeah maybe they are some kind of special
race who are bonded with these creatures and and
you know Bound by duty to protect them or whatever
um but dudes I love this trailer uh so much I am
so jacked I am jacked I really love this yeah
no absolutely this has all the fun and and like
promise of wacky you know more broad expansions
and it's fascinating to see what we America choose
to do to up the ante while you know you also have
immediate examples of what Japan's doing to up
the ante and it's just a fun time to be a Godzilla
fan G yeah I agree John guys what you think about
the trailer leave your thoughts down below be
sure to subscribe leave a like I got to get this
video to deliver to all yall and uh support us
at reject Nation shop.com let's get to [Music] it